[Music]
so what I can share with you today is
not an answer to the question of what is
hope but I can share with you about how
a tradition that I'm involved in
studying and I'm linked to has a take on
what ways of hoping may be better or
more useful than others right so my
understanding of this tradition that I
have studied and engaged with for a few
years now it's the african-american
Protestant tradition of hoping what's
crafted over centuries of despair and
dehumanization right right and I think
it has something to teach our nation our
nation that has that has in some ways
undermined this very tradition of hoping
right and the nation in some ways has
trivialized hope itself made something
hope into something that's largely a
market driven quest for getting our
aspirations for reaching our goals for
achieving our aims I think one of the
things that not unpacking the
distinction between Obama's hopes and
Kings hopes based on the painting which
I'm going to describe now is it leaves
us more vulnerable to romantic
conceptions of hope right we tend to
fall into this this this way of thinking
about hope that's more reflective almost
of what Shelley called in Prometheus
Unbound 1822 he said we want he wants to
hope till hope creates from its own
wreck the thing it contemplates it's a
beautiful line right and I'm susceptible
and seduced by that kind of Hope but
when I think about King and Obama in
this painting I tend to get more clear
about what is deep hope right so I want
to highlight quickly the distinction
between both King and Obama and then
I'll be done I think this will help us
understand both what I'm trying to get
at and where we are now so first Kings
hope his description of hope is always
disappointed
and never realized while Obama's hope
guides us past disappointment and is
realizable so here we have a clear
difference between the Protestant
embrace of a tragic sense of life and
the kind of democratic politics of Hope
that aims to resist the politics of
cynicism right and that's fine so
important thing to remember though is
that the difference in the Protestants
the Protestant embrace of tragedy
attenuates our inclinations for happy
ending right it works against that
romantic conception that I argued I
pointed out Shelley was referencing in
1820 Prometheus Unbound quote by
romantic sense to hope until hope
reaches what it contemplates right
second Kings Hope is a discipline of the
present moment the social practice done
in community with the aim of reminding
us that our lives are always incomplete
and unfinished our deep hopes will not
come to fruition is King's point in this
way we might say Kings Hope is a way of
relationship it is a relating to
suffering tells us to just keep going
Obama's hope on the other hand is an
aspiration for the future it's a
rational belief about the probability of
attainment painting one ambitions you
might say that Obama's hope attends to
the pressures of achievement by
affirming aspirations for the future so
I quickly I want to caution you from
taking what I'm saying as a way of
thinking about Martin's account as just
another form of tragic hope dark hope
melancholic hope I hope against hope
hope of the hopeless right because I
think that I think Kings hope to simply
be a reminder
of the idea of the tragic in our life
the notion that our mortal days will not
be fulfilled so it's dark in essence but
I don't think I don't want to pitch it
as a dark hope right so I want to pitch
it as a deep hope right and when people
go with melancholic hope or blues hope I
think they often end up romanticizing a
kind of Hope that seduces us into
thinking there may it be a hope without
suffering that is the idea of a dark
hope relies on the idea of a light hope
and I had all kind of problems right
analogically but just the fact that both
things sort of have to seem like they
have to exist together is misleading and
it skirts the fundamental inside of
Martin which is to remind us of a
certain kind of suffering now for King a
man who we often associate with things
like the I have a dream speech right the
song we shall overcome he's telling us
in 59 63 and later on in 68 he gives a
sermon called unfulfilled dreams where
he continues this theme that all our
hopes are blasted and our dreams are
shattered in other words the person we
think of as the amazing hoeper and
dreamer is really trying to tell us
something most differently he's trying
to difference he's trying to tell us our
hopes our perfidious and George
Butterick notes we die with half our
music in us so you might ask then what
is the purpose of this sort of Hope why
would I want to subscribe to it and
that's the vision hope is not up for a
subscription it's a way of relating to
suffering and facing the ultimate fact
that we shall likely not achieve all of
the promises of life but this is just
what life is in this strand of
Protestantism it is not life's failing
King tells us that the tentacles of evil
are always present taking meaning out of
life but we must go on we must have the
will to refuse
must have what till it called the power
the courage to be this I think is the
link between Martin King in the watts
painting both are fundamentally trying
to affirm a relationship between
suffering to continuing right Martin is
dealing with the death of dreams watts I
think is dealing with the death of his
reportedly his stepdaughter the number
Deloitte's when he lost little Burghardt
in 1899
Burghardt was 18 months old Dubois came
up with it wrote that he was feeling a
hope quote I hope not hopeful but on
hopeless the messages once again that
our hopes are shattered the shattering
provides a path to suffering that allows
deeper meaning this is what deep hope is
about so when students ask me why do I
hope I turn to Martin these questions of
course has we have recently increased
right not because people are minded
necessarily more depressed but because I
think they don't understand and be Pope
that Martin was trying to call us to so
let me just end by saying this Obama is
not the only it's not Obama's fault that
we don't we're not attentive to deep
hopes that Martin was trying to call us
to based on his interpretation of the
painting global marketers have made hope
into a rational calculation for personal
gain gain many academics have subjected
helps to stand as an analytic precision
and conceptual clarity kind of degraded
then certainly diminished by Christian
leaders who reduced hope to a form of
compliant this has led to a loss in our
appetite for hope deep hope that is we
want the romantic hope but not the deep
kindness in touch with suffering this is
the kind of tradition that I've been
studying tradition and Martin and
Jeremiah Wright Fred Sampson linked to
the painting of George Frederick Watson
1886 and as I leave you with an
invitation to the painting as well as
one 2d Pope thank you very kindly
[Music]